Donald Trump wasted almost no time
in attacking Ron DeSantis after
desantis's big win in the State of
Florida and Trump is also going after
the media over an election disaster that
he brought on himself there's a good
article in the New York Times called
Trump Under Fire from within Republican
party after the midterms a longtime
advisor said Republicans have followed
Donald Trump off the side of a cliff
Trump flipped out on Truth social which
he also calls truth Central
yeah as as you know Trump not only has
gotten his own name wrong he's gotten
the name of his own social media
platform wrong as well check out some of
these posts on Truth quote while in
certain ways yesterday's election was
somewhat disappointing from my personal
standpoint it was a very big victory
It's All About Him 219 wins and 16
losses in the general who has ever done
better than that remember I don't know
how many times I I have to tell you this
I note Trump and the Republicans are
refusing to accept it he mostly endorsed
incumbents
and republican nominees in easy red
districts where whoever is the
Republican nominee they're going to win
you can run up the score very easily the
16 losses are consequential control of
the Senate hinges on those 16 losses
control of the election systems by
Governors and secretaries of State in
2024 hinges on those losses but Trump
wants to assist 219 and 16. okay here's
where it gets very ugly very quickly
Trump in his next post saying quote now
that the election in Florida is over
and everything went quite well shouldn't
it be said that in 2020 I got 1.1
million more votes in Florida than Ron
DeSantis got this year 5.7 million to
4.6 million just asking
there is one interpretation of this
truth
and it is that Trump is realizing
the energy is getting behind DeSantis
the strength of the Republican
electorate is Shifting like a storm
coming in and changing the direction of
the wind towards Ron DeSantis and so he
immediately needs to make the case I'm
stronger than DeSantis even in Florida
now if we want to take this seriously
you have to remember turnout is lower in
midterms and gubernatorial elections
that coincide with a midterm rather than
a general election tend to have lower
turnout
is there maybe something to the claim
that Florida would prefer Trump over the
DeSantis in a presidential race sure I
don't know I'm not taking a position on
that I don't know if a primary in the
Republican party in Florida were held
today whether it would be DeSantis or
Trump I don't know that but this is
already a full frontal attack on Ronda
Sanders Trump is reportedly seething
about what's going on with Florida he
didn't even invite Ron DeSantis to his
rally on Sunday choosing instead only to
have Marco Rubio there he did mention
yeah yeah vote for Ron DeSantis but it
is very clear that Trump is furious with
DeSantis another one of these truths
Trump then going after the media
remember it's me me DeSantis bad media
bad typical narcissist Trump says quote
incredible how dishonest the fake news
media is the failing New York Times has
gone crazy so many of the people I
capital E endorsed went on to Victory on
Tuesday night nobody was even close and
they literally make up a story refusing
to write the facts and only quoting
enemies in and losers almost all of the
people I endorsed won yet if you read
the story from two trump-hating writers
who only do as they are told you would
not even recognize the truth they truly
are the enemy of the people again
remember the Articles recognize that
when it came to the critical
consequential races Trump endorsed
mostly people who lost in the critical
would make a difference races and then
Trump again restating quote 219 wins
against 16 losses in the general
election and yet the fake news
writes only unrecognizable junk no
wonder they are all doing so badly this
is an absurd framing look at all of the
people Trump endorsed who lost Oz
fetterman Dixon John Gibbs lost remember
when I interviewed him he was defeated
J.R Majewski lost thank goodness the
2018 midterms under Trump were not good
for Republicans the 2020 presidential
was lost and then they lost everything
disaster in 2022 so now what are
Republicans ready to say bye bye to
Donald Trump or are they going to try it
again in 2024 let me know what you think
you've heard me talk about the accounts
we've had hacked it's a horrible
experience it can happen to anyone look
up the stats if it hasn't happened to
you yet it may at some point protecting
yourself against scammers online can get
complicated our sponsor Aura is the
all-in-one solution that I now use to
keep accounts safe Aura scans the dark
web for your personal info emails
passwords Social Security numbers
immediately alerts you if anything is
found helps you fix the problem you also
get alerts about suspicious credit
inquiries or automatically request the
removal of your information from search
engines and data broker sites and Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware with its state-of-the-art
antivirus and Aura also helps you manage
what your kids can do on their devices
with very simple easy to use parental
device controls you can try Aura free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman your
login credentials might already be
floating around it takes only a few
seconds on Aura to figure that out and
think of all of the other useful things
you'll discover during the two-week
trial the link is down below